[Musique]
avec une émission qui jugent l'apparence
de ses candidates cristina cordula joue
avec le feu si aujourd'hui les rapports
au corps et l'acceptation de tous les
physiques est au coeur des débats
l'airé du shopping peut parfois dérangé
c'est ce qui est arrivé avec l'émission
diffusée lundi dernier sur m6 dédié aux
femmes rondes
la styliste brésilienne a créé la
polémique avec un conseil jugés déplacés
un conseil qui donnait une astuce dont
le but d'effacer les rondeurs d'une
candidate
[Musique]
immédiatement les réseaux sociaux se
sont enflammés accusant l'animatrice de
tenir des propos grosso fob quand vous
avez des rondeurs ne portait pas de
décolleté elle m'agace cristina cordula
meta 1
habillez vous comme vous voulez soyez
libres hashtag grossophobie déjà il ya
quelques mois l'animatrice avait été
épinglé pour les mêmes raisons dans son
émission la robe de ma vie dont le
contenu avait également été jugée grosso
faible
festif et dans le sud est c'est la
musique aulas oui un peu de nuance
honnêtement oui elle donne des conseils
sont là pour avoir des conseils d'une
bâtisse icaunais a priori effectivement
c'est pas grave y'a quelqu'un tu devrais
tu devrais pas mettre quelque chose qui
te qui te met pas en valeur
voilà c'est tout il ya rien de gagner
gros sous forme là dedans honnêtement
c'est une star je suis pas du tout
d'accord avec benjamin parce que christ
en tant que l'acquis essence c'est
mettre les femmes à l'aise et où elle
conseille aux femmes avec des rondeurs
de mettre des vêtements amples à partir
de là oui c'est grosso fob et oui ça
peut choquer je comprend du coup tout à
fait gilbert eychenne êtes d'accord avec
cynthia absolument il faut castaldi déjà
fait un spécial femmes rondes mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire à la cigm
attisant en soit ils font ça parce
qu'ils avaient été accusés ya quelques
années ou quelques mois attendait d'être
grossophobie voulait se rattraper ces
couples alors raté juste je vous le dis
isabelle vous allez avoir qu'une
occasion de défendre un petit ce soir
c'est sûr maintenant il me sera
pratiquée cette émission mais sont
volontaires et conseillons reprochent de
donner des combats bien maxime là c'est
taper pour taper cette news ode à la
femme ronde
non merci
les deux sociétés et ça veut pas dire
que dans l'émission c'est là pas fait
appel à d'autres femmes rondes
donc c'est bien l'admettre de les mettre
en valeur et connaissant cassina
connaissent elles seraient capables de
faire une semaine en h ausse avec les
corps en achat donc elle est capable de
tout et c'est bien mettre toutes les
femmes en avant a compris ni aux
dauphins monde ni stigmatisant monde pas
de vienne il ya des émissions spéciales
dender spécial ce qu'ils mangent pas
ceux qui découvraient à dormir cetera
c'est ainsi de la télévision dans ta
faute jour taille dans le sens du vent
excuse moi mais ce qui supposerait la
réalité sont comme ça aux femmes c'est
toujours ceux qui sont très minces
castéra il ya plein de femmes rondes
qu'aimerait bien par l armée c'est
normal qu'on fasse des émissions pour
lequel soie bleue se sentir et énervé
oui tu mélanges les morphologies
pourquoi faire une émission spéciale
rond les rênes du shopping c'est un
concours pour voir qui va s'habiller le
mieux en fonction d'un thème mais on
n'est pas dans le thème contre l'obésité
c'est que tu parles de morphologie mais
morphologie ça peut être h ça peut être
en donc c'est justement la gentille
bon moi je sois d'accord avec ce qu'elle
bien mais quand tu fais le toi de
morphologie je suis pas d'accord avec
toi parce que justement on s'habille
selon sa morphologie poursuivre les
choses infâmes qu'elle soit finie ou
plus rondes pourra choisir la tenue est
plus adéquat en big 5 5 font le jeudi
c'est un match que je parle de moi
regarder en bas beaucoup choqué on vous
a fait une petite compil des propos de
cristina cordula qui ont choqué j'ai
choisi ce thème parce que la solidité
c'est super féminin et ça va très bien
aux rondes tous et qui brille le satan
sa marque toutes les imperfections
certes c'est fluide mais c'est pas fait
pour ta morphologie
moi honnêtement personnellement le
legging ça va pas du tout le pantalon
foncé comme ça oui
des pantalons qui sont évasée alors que
là le moule on il vaut mieux pas les
slims ça va battre c'est tout ce qui est
basé bout de code c'est l'idéal pourtant
pas ce que ça va équilibrer les bas avec
tes hanches si vous êtes ronde célébrons
accessoires qui nous va le 5
la robe la longueur 7 longueurs qui est
trop courte pour toi et puis j'ai
l'impression qu'elle s'est un peu de
boulot bah oui ça du coup j'ai
l'impression que ça grossit un peu
important il vaut mieux pas volé vaut
mieux marquer la taille est parti à
l'évasion
[Applaudissements]
mais quand j'entends les conseils de
cristina cordula je me dis est ce que
n'importe qui peut s'habiller comme ils
l'entendent
pourquoi pas d'autant quand on est ronde
être obligés de s'habiller avec des
pincettes même peuple et moi je pars du
principe qu'on n'est toujours pas en
train de parler de la grossophobie mais
on ne parle pas assez de la négrophobie
c'est pareil dans le sens inverse
s'appellerait semaine prochaine pour la
semaine prochaine elle a dit voilà il
savait